this is such a opener for all these guys
to be like I'll take you to Grand cage
yeah
which destination you would like to take
Colleen but don't try to rail her just
try to take her somewhere nice yeah
please don't try to rail me
[Music]
welcome back to careful boys we are very
careful boys and today we're joined by
Colleen I'll be obviously
you're gonna kick us off all right what
is the most beautiful travel spot you
have ever been to and somewhere you're
like every time I go there I could
finally just shut everything off and
chill that's what I need to do more of
in my life you need to relax yeah relax
for sure I did that in my bed I need to
do that I need to travel more Joe's like
my bad I can tell you where I want to go
you please
um Bora Bora I would love to go to
Greece Santorini
beautiful place I'd say Japan but I
don't want to kick this one off
we just gotta move on to the next number
please
the guy with the three teeth
okay so back to Greece I want to go to
Greece
really that's your number one that's
your number one spot Santorini no it's
actually it's more Asia but we're trying
to avoid that you want to go to Greece
that's your spot
um yeah do you like cold beaches like
real cold water
um yeah I do I take cold showers oh what
about the what about places you have
been what has been your favorite dude
I've only been to like within the states
and in Mexico which I don't count oh
what about in the states there's not a
beautiful place in the states too there
are
um
I mean I would say here's the problem
too is just like I'm such a [__]
workaholic it's so boring so it's like
even if I go to those states are you
always editing I only have like certain
moments of of free time to be exploring
and my work is so like physical that
like I'm exhausted there's no time to
you can't count so like what are what
are some places that I should travel to
like I haven't even been to the Grand
Canyon Costa Rica oh my God don't go to
the Grand Canyon first of all I love the
grandkids yeah but everybody's like oh
that's such a like an easy quick trip
like or like Yosemite I think Yosemite
right now is actually to go to Yosemite
as [__] is sick yeah like yo somebody
would be a place this is such a opener
for all these guys to be like I'll take
you to Grand Canyon yeah
and comment below uh which destination
you would like to take Colleen that's
why I'm almost my travel but don't try
to rail her just try to take her
somewhere nice yeah please don't try to
rail me
that's good to see you intentions like
that you can go to the Grand Canyon on a
helicopter trip and then they have lunch
ready for you and then you can have a
little date at the bottom of the Grand
Canyon and then you go back on the
helicopter and then you go I think it's
like 400 bucks I like activities so like
I rode a horse in Cabo like on the beach
like a horse in the ocean it was like
very movie-like that's so easy to
picture because you're a white chick
yeah totally uh I picture this no saddle
again
no saddle white robe like a Roman
princess hair out and then the [__]
read and then just yeah that's nice I'm
glad you guys pictured it that way
because it's definitely not how it looks
how it looked was like my horse took off
and it was like go for a moment but then
like you're like oh [__] like this
motherfucker's not stopping you're like
kicking your heels you're making sure
that you can't go whoa yeah you're
trying the dirt instructor how does your
like instructor or a person so he was
super chill so like he just rides up
next to you and it cuts you off so the
horse stops and that's what he did but
my saddle wasn't like fully
um measured for me and tightened so like
as a horse is taking off I'm sliding oh
so like I'm trying to like like a
[__] Mongolian Archer
pulling it out oh so I'm sliding half
the time and right before I think like
this leg's about to kick off whoa sick
dude so it was cool for like the first
like five minutes no wonder you stressed
out on vacations yeah
right right I'm like zip lining or
horseback riding or like skydiving I'm
like curd though I can't like just sit
on the beach I like doing things so if
we were on a beach I'd probably be like
in the water snorkeling or doing
something I'm cool with that I like
doing stuff as long as I can be in the
water at some point yeah one of the
things that I hated most as a kid is my
uncles had a boat and we would go
fishing but then I couldn't go in the
water and you're a kid you just want to
go in the water oh this is not safe
because it was like Lake water in
Virginia
Southern Lakes are crystal clear this
one was not Hawaii Hawaii is amazing you
can't beat Hawaii dude it's warm Bahamas
pretty great I've never been in Boston
Bahamas water beats Hawaii but I love
Hawaii yeah because it's warmer or looks
nice the turquoise it looks like fake
Resort water it's like clearer clear wow
see your feet all the way at the bottom
and I'm six foot four it's kind of crazy
to see your feet that is pretty crazy
because it's that clear it's back there
I like the cenotes in all over King
it's like a cave Beach it's like a
natural opening yeah it's just you look
at a hole and then it's like this
beautiful Oasis and you can go down and
swim and you're just like what the hell
is happening and there's fish and some
of them are scary dude yeah one time we
went to this one where this guy had to
take us all the way through and it was
like you're crawling through caves like
little tiny little entrances and then
bats were flying past oh [__] that was
[__] scary and we were the only ones
in there and then he took us to this one
area where you would just float and if
you look down after the water it gets
still enough you could see like hundreds
of feet all the way down below you and
it's so [__] scary if you guys watch
those videos of like um Navy guys on
like breaks when they're on the aircraft
carriers and they'll just like jump like
from the aircraft carrier into the water
and then when you when you think about
where they're at in like the Pacific
Ocean or the Atlantic Ocean
it's like the Titanic's down there like
like that kind of deep that freaks the
[__] out that's one of the scariest
things
if you've ever been on a cruise ship and
then you're there and you look off the
side and you can't see anything yeah
you're like the [__] ocean is the
facts nothing yeah that's terrifying
remember when we went to swim with
sharks that was crazy you guys swim with
sharks yeah cage though but that's still
scary because when they pull up they're
like really big it's kind of hard to
just describe how massive it is because
the when the boat turns off they just
start circling and fast because I
remember being on the boat I would see
the shark like this and it comes and
then it literally you turn around and
it's already there whoa like like that
like little Torpedoes they're bigger
than the boat yeah and then you they
come up and you can like touch them like
what kind of sharks are they Galapagos
yeah what kind of shark is that I mean
like it's a [__] tiger shark
they have tiger sharks too those are the
ones that bite humans yeah [__] that but
we are we go in the cage and then they
just swim around you and like man it's
like crazy and you go you look down and
you can't see the bottom of the ocean
it's crazy dude one time I swam with the
dolphins when I was a kid
and it was like a resort and it was like
maybe the most depressing thing I've
ever done did they [__] it was so sad
that's because they wouldn't [__] me
yeah no because when you're a kid like
see meeting the Dolphins maybe one of
the coolest things I could ever happen
of course and then I was swimming with
the dolphins with the snorkel on but
like they were so I could just tell they
were so depressed they felt their sad
energy dude it was like a weird energy
in the water yeah that's kind of like
the the rescue Dolphins at SeaWorld when
they come out and you can feed them they
all like come out like in a stampede and
they all look like [__] up gang
members dude like they all got a scratch
on their face like because they're all
rescue Dolphins right are they all
rescue Dolphins I don't know right
they'll come out
you're supposed to be able to feed them
and like pet them and then they don't
let you really pet them they let you
pedal just a second and then they're
like give me food give me food I saw a
really happy when he waved at me like
that and then he went all the way so I
know he was
has this beautiful turtle pond
[Laughter]
one of the coolest places we've been to
recently was um and we didn't get a
chance to explore it that much but it
was the big Island's Volcano National
Park oh Hawaii Big Island too it was
really [__] cool and at the time we
went to go see it there was an active
volcano erupting oh so like we would go
late at night
and then we could just see like lava
lava dude and like feet of it now
because we were about a mile away but
it's still you could see everything and
it was cool it was pretty dope and then
it's pitch black as well too so you have
to walk you have to take the trail all
the way back to your car how late was it
it was probably like nine o'clock and
then you can see but the lava was red
it's it's easy to Glow darker yeah
that's pretty cool did you try throwing
things in it nah I don't have my arms
not that good
um Brady's arms yeah dude it was like a
mile away it was hella far but then also
we went to the highest point in the Big
Island which was called like Mauna Kea
and then they have all these really cool
giant um like space telescopes that are
made by like MIT uh Caltech the one that
Jason Momoa wants to get out yeah oh
really that's the place that they're
protesting because they're like why are
you trying to put 10 more telescopes and
[__] we already got enough oh yeah well
I think they want to do some high-tech
[__] with it apparent according to um
but apparently some places in Hawaii
like what you could see of the uh like
[__] galaxies and [__] it's the only
place in the world that you can see so
that's the argument and that's a thing
right there's no light pollution so then
they they did like a tour guide of like
all the stars and stuff and when it was
really dark that was really cool because
usually we go there for beaches and all
that so we don't get a chance to be at
the highest peak and and you people are
getting Like Oxygen poisoning and stuff
being like Tiff kind of was like kind of
[__] up is that high it's that high
whoa it's I think it's like 14 000
something something crazy elevator game
in Denver and it was like that I got
lightheaded like going to like watching
the Broncos game and then they have like
they have every time you climb up
another couple thousand feet they have
like all these different um like warning
signs of like make sure you know you're
staying hydrated you have oxygen tank
did you walk or drive they drove they
drove all the way it was like a little
Charter but it was really fun I've never
been a big island you gotta go I've
never been in there I want to go too it
feels like it's it's like eight
different terrains on one island is that
relaxing for you Nick are you like a
sightseeing kind of guy you gotta go to
the volcanoes I feel like we gotta do
some [__] we gotta go do stuff but it is
like afterwards it's like tiring but you
get to see stuff that you never get to
see in California or in Pasadena
Pasadena my favorite routine is
eat something yummy yep do something
eat something yummy and then relax yeah
and then eat something yummy and then
sleep that's my travel sounds kind of
crazy that's pretty hot we might want to
edit that up that's my favorite travel
routine
that's my favorite well some people want
to do something yummy
some people do three things in a day
that's not me yeah I just do one like
one hike then we eat and then we pass
out on the beach and then eat and then
that is really nice we like to jam
packed my thing too is like when I get
there I like to get sunburned
immediately sit the tone yeah imitation
crab every time I'm even near the sun
I'm like oh [__] but then I'm such a
deals guy I'm like I have to get the
[__] value so then I'll make myself
that sounds relaxing thank you is there
places where you guys want to go but you
haven't been to yet [__] the rest of
the world exactly Thailand definitely I
still haven't done South America and
Africa I want to see Mount Rushmore I
don't even see that [__] that's
disappointing yeah it hurts tiny did
Anthony say that Anthony said that cool
being all over the world huh yeah he's
seen it at all you know what maybe Mount
rushmore's kind of tight
maybe it's not disappointing at all
maybe it's the sickest [__] ever yeah
I'll go to Egypt Egypt I heard it's full
of con artists yeah dude
everyone hates Egypt really yeah
everyone comes back don't [__] go
there there's like super famous like
food vloggers that are like man it's
full of corrupt ass cops and they steal
your [__] it's horrible they all have
horrible experiences the closer you are
to the pyramids too there's more people
trying to sell you Trinkets and [__]
yeah oh that's cool yeah I love trinkets
like the pyramids are so close to the
city so it's like you think that you're
just going to be in this vast emptiness
and then you just see the piercings what
if I have a t-shirt that says I started
kova 19. they will bother you see you
gotta wear the bike you'll beat him to
the punch every time you might be able
to buy a wristband that says that you
can definitely buy wristbands
but they don't know you got to do it in
their language oh yeah that's true
Chinese
oh yeah you know what's nice too that I
recently wanted to do more of is go to
snow towns oh you know like Veil or like
um like Aspen like yeah like Aspen yeah
yeah
you want to go during during the snow or
you want to go now during the snow yeah
because I think that's just like a it's
like the flip side directly from what
I'm used to here so when you go to these
like little like smaller Villages and
you know you see the people that
actually live there and the businesses
that they have it's pretty you're
talking about snow like
tourist spots or towns that are like
um like below the mountain that actually
operate but they get snow I think I
would rather go to tourist snow towns
first oh I see go deeper from there
because right I have no clue what to
look for unless it's a tourist town I
feel like Snow's cool for like about a
day and then you're like this is just a
big inconvenience yeah because back in
the day we did I did go to uh when X
Games was on in Aspen and arrived we did
a show there once and then walking
around it just feels like a total like
180 yeah yeah and it's nice it's cold
it's kind of like Hot Tub Time Machine
where they're in the Kodiak Valley it's
like that type of vibe yeah yeah I love
the snow life I always wanted to give my
family get a cabin for Christmas time
yep and then we're all there cozy that'd
be cool
if I wanted to get a cabin here in Big
Bear but then our like Hills here it or
mountains it it feels like a city in the
mountains it's too crowded like it's not
like Mammoth or Tahoe where it's more
spread out I can't stay in a [__]
A-Frame house dude I'll [__] kill
myself well I'm after getting snowed in
too every time you stay in one of those
bunk beds dude the ceilings yeah it's
like something in a goddamn coffin
cabins I've been to in Big Bear are
[__] nuts yeah have you seen those
Log Cabin Mansions yeah it's like I
stated when it was that's pretty crazy
we I don't want to brag but we happen to
stay in one that was previously stayed
in right before us by Machine Gun Kelly
and uh Megan Fox oh [__] was a lot of
[__] on the ground they said they had to
they had to drain the jacuzzi before I
bet before we went there and I was like
oh wow Jesus they're probably busting it
down all over that goddamn house dude no
one making foxes in there though people
would pay yeah people would pay it was a
selling point for the Airbnb lady how'd
you know how do you know because she
told us they probably unscrew the toilet
seat and keep it
is that screw the toilet
to do
unbolting the toilet taking it putting
in a plastic bag we're gonna save this
fox use this toilet and people like dude
I'm not buying your [__] thing I it's
fine please don't tell me that it sat
here
make it butt touched it
dude but I really like Zion man Zion was
beautiful too where's that at it said
Utah okay and it's like the war we
stayed we stayed in this little town
called hurricane which is probably like
25 minutes away yeah yeah yeah and it
was just like a cool ass little town
um really nice house that we stayed in
but just the whole vibe in Zion that was
my first national park I've ever been to
and it just felt like Disneyland of like
hiking you know you'll love Yosemite
yeah I think that's next especially
right now I hear right now we went to
Zan earlier this year too when it was
snowing and it's crazy like how like uh
like big bear it's like kind of naturey
but then like some of the other parts
like Yosemite is on it's like wait
anymore it's like on steroids yeah and
there's the Red Rocks man those are
crazy we had those in Las Vegas
we went to this one part so we just
pulled off to the side and we kind of
hiked down and then we found a creek and
then it was cool to see like snow coming
down but the water's still running and
then just like patches of snow are just
floating down river that felt like a
movie you just felt like a movie it was
like wow I almost won other than arrows
like around the area the the what do
they call it the the hike where you walk
in the water did you guys oh we didn't
do that one no there's a there's a
couple of like more of the you're
supposed to do them we didn't do those
but we should have you know what you
know what I heard and I'm not sure if
it's true I heard that it's really good
to go to Midian now really why now yeah
yeah because there's no more crack
dealers well there's no they like
cleaned it up apparently and it's like
super great to like visit it oh let me
tight yeah Gene Escobar's prison would
be safe like his Mansion prison oh that
would be cool isn't El Salvador doing
really nice yeah dude because they
cleaned it all up it's it's definitely
like oh because of Bitcoin baby yeah
it's it's pretty cool over there bro
like it's pretty everything seems pretty
accessible everything felt pretty safe
when I was there and we got to hike up
this uh the sulfur volcano that [__] was
pretty tight because there's only like
four in the world and we got to get a
chance to see one which was pretty cool
you only go to places with volcanoes it
smells kind of or Calabasas you're a
volcano Chaser yeah
it's like twister but yeah it doesn't it
doesn't move away yeah yeah yeah it did
smell like [__] up there though and it
didn't make your eyes burn a little bit
but it was tight because it was like
because you like that smell it was blue
yeah I love the smell
I go back to Costa Rica
because I had kidney stones when I was
there and it was like nightmare but how
early in your trip in Costa Rica did you
get kidney stones day two oh how many
days were you there too many days
I was there for five days but we cut the
strip early because I yeah we had to
peace out but then um when we first got
there we were staying like
not too far from the airport like
probably 30 minutes away
we're on a beach it looks like Island
nebula from [__] Jurassic Park like
it's unbelievable and then I was like
man I wish we were staying here the
whole [__] time and he said well
we're going next was even better then we
get on a bus for four hours they drive
us all the way down like the middle of
the [__]
um Island so there's no water anywhere
and then like we're just staying at like
a shitty beach with rocks all over it
really yeah and they they're like the
one patch of water that was there it was
like freezing cold compared to the other
place did you get to see some monkeys
dude I got to see the sky mostly because
I was on my back like pretty much the
rest of the time because he got hurt
yeah yeah the kidney kidney stones dude
got land loaded into a station wagon
ambulance
[__] hilarious yeah
but that's where I go I give it a take
too nice to have a redo yeah Costa Rica
must be beautiful that's why I heard it
it's beautiful though I'm gonna go
definitely a top top list it is pretty
good also it is really nice too
Guatemala really Guatemala's really
never heard anything about watermelon
really I don't believe you yeah I was
lying I just made it up
we made it up
I'll go to Russia
thank you